fructueuse et constructive voilà comment
washington et téhéran ont résumé leur
première journée de discussions une
entrevue de près de deux heures sans
face à face direct dans ce luxueux hôtel
de la capitale autrichienne en compagnie
bien sûr des signataires du gie cypihot
et le plan d'action global commun le
tout sous l'égide de l'union européenne
oui nous voyons cela comme une étape
constructive et bienvenue et en fin de
compte nous espérons pouvoir quitter
vienne retourner aux états unis
notre équipe de négociation devrais-je
dire avec une meilleure idée de la
feuille de route qui nous permettra
d'atteindre cet objectif le respect
mutuel le respect de l'accord par l'iran
et la manière dont les états unis
pourrait également retourner dans
l'accord je peux dire que dans
l'ensemble cette réunion a été
constructive
nous avons convenu de mettre en place de
groupes de travail l'un sur les
sanctions et l'autre sur le domaine
nucléaire ces deux groupes de travail
sont composés de tous les membres de la
commission mixte c'est à dire des
experts iraniens ainsi que des experts
des pays du p4 poussins sans la présence
des états unis les états unis ne seront
présents à aucune réunion avec l'iran
c'est notre politique définitive il n'y
a aucun doute à ce sujet
les etats unis se disent prêts à lever
les sanctions qui sont en contradiction
avec l'accord condition sinequanone pour
que l'iran renoue avec ses engagements
nucléaires dont le pays s'est
progressivement a franchi depuis le
retrait de washington en 2018
l'ex-président américain donald trump
avait dénoncé unilatéralement ce pacte
conclu à vienne en 2015 visant à
garantir que téhéran ne cherche pas à se
doter de la bombe atomique mais joe
biden souhaite le réintégrer et depuis
son arrivée à la maison blanche les
différentes parties s'active en coulisse
un rétablissement de l'accord qui ne
surviendra pas immédiatement
la maison blanche a dit s'attendre à un
processus long et difficile